we call him cruise control for me and
see how it goes a deal if for whatever
reason I wind up covering the new top
sub movie I'm going to say hello cruise
control just to see what happens what if
he just goes Wow and then hello everyone
welcome back for a brand new episode of
Collider ladies night I say this all the
time this is an extra special episode of
the show because we have Gillian Belle
the star of Brittany runs a marathon
here and I'm just gonna like to start
big I am running the New York City
Marathon this year because of that
moving what I know you told me that at
Sundance I was right and that was the
first essential was myself again told me
I was so sad that when you guys came
into our interview suite at Sundance
that I hadn't seen the movie yet and
then finally a couple days later I got
to see it for myself and I think I cried
through the entire third act of the film
oh my goodness I'm sorry and three my
whole life the world told me I was lazy
because the way I look but trying to
turn my life around everything's gonna
be fine
people help doors for making all doors
for you you changed your life was never
about your weight was about you taking
responsibility for your stead of the
training is cruising along and hopefully
I get there and finished where are you
at now where are you at now and right
now we are at an 8 mile run over the
weekend so it's that point where like
I'm semi getting it done but the wheels
in my head keep turning and I keep
thinking about how much further I have
to go and it freaks me out a little does
your brain tell you I'd like to stop now
yes go see a movie it does the cure for
that though I found ok a good audiobook
oh you book yeah as long as you like the
story you're listening to I find that I
could keep going and going and going and
then I would do that with this American
life I would listen to NPR a lot start
doing that I was doing it with Howard
Stern interviews for a while and that
that kept me going for like a full out
that's right yeah I did that or I would
do I would put up together a playlist of
like pitbull it's like what people we
used to go out like getting ready for a
big night out
music was my like go-to I feel about
it's late running most people would have
on their running playlist but I run and
then all of a sudden the you know the
themes of Halloween or a piece the score
from us kicks in and then I just I'm off
and running do you listen to the scores
of horror films and I always have a
running playlist and most of the music
is like alternative rock that are alien
to and gets me going but I also have
random pieces of score that pops in as
well I'm so happy I have this thing on
my phone I don't I'm not great at well
doing most things in life but I'm really
not great with technology so I will
download songs or upload them or
whatever the kids are saying and then I
also have songs on there that are little
clips from when I used to sketch shows
at The Groundlings and so all the sudden
eliciting and there's you know some song
from Drake and then all of a sudden it's
just a woman screaming for 30 seconds
the really awkward thing is when I first
got started doing this and I used to do
interviews I would record them on my
phone so they would automatically go to
my iTunes so every once in a while it
had friends over and I'd be playing my
music in the Sun it would be like a
crackly interview that I did god knows
how long I'm so happy this happens to
you cuz I feel like you're very hip and
with-it and so that makes me feel better
yeah that that also happens to you I had
one where I was in the car with someone
and I think I was trying to impress them
too it might have been a handsome
gentleman and then all of a sudden it
was like a 45-second fart like off the
45-second fake fart in there that was
for a sketch and I know exactly which
sketch cuz I wrote it and I'm not proud
of it but I was like why why did this
have to play this in there because when
I edit my own videos every once in a
while you buy Saturday while I fart I
mean do that I mean that happens it
could happen here I accidentally dropped
the sound effect file into my iTunes
instead of my premiere that's what
happens is it goes on the list
oh so it's like all of a sudden I'll be
playing my music and it'll be like I
don't know like the shutter sound of a
camera
I have one look like just like a a whip
where it's like watch and I'm like I
don't okay I should go on my running
playlist that's a good way in between
it's like you know with me and she's
encouraging you to keep going I wanted
to hit the beginning of your career
because I had read that you always
wanted to get into comedy so I was
curious what was kind of either the
gateway comedian the gateway movie
anything at all that kind of made you
say this is what I want to do right well
my favorite movie of all time is clue
it's my favorite movie Tim Curry and
Madeline Kahn and I mean the whole cast
is amazing and but yeah Tim Curry's
performance in that movie I just watched
it over and over again as a kid and I
still watch it to this day it's it's one
of my favorite movies because it's all
character actors playing the leads and
they're all making such bold choices
throughout it and that's a mix of comedy
and a little bit of horror and and a
murder mystery it's all my favorite
things in one film it's a solid choice
right there thank you what's your
favorite film Jurassic Park I'm great
you asked that's a great thing is a
great film tell me about your love for
that photo I would be happy to most
people out there know this know I have a
Jurassic Park tattoo you do that I love
it's it's like right then oh Syria show
they're not the main dinosaur the lead
dinosaur you'll get a kick out of this
Sam Jackson wrote down hold on to your
butts and then I took that piece of
paper and I got it tattooed and he saw a
pic it's in an appropriate spot when I'm
wearing shorts but he saw a picture of
the finished product that's a myth
that's a great time yeah if you were to
get a clue tattoo what would it be it
would probably be Oh what is the
statement though popular in Cantonese
cuisine monkeys brain is not often to be
found in Washington DC that's one of my
favorite lines I just love the idea of
that be
it's so so incompatible you see here
that's why I'm so buttoned up it's just
going all the way down that's a mystery
that everyone can finger it could be
there so clue was the game-changer for
you yes it's one thing to say to
yourself I want to be in movies or I
want to be a comedian but it's another
thing to really feel like it was a
possibility so what was the first gig
you got that major say this could be the
real deal for me like this could be my
career I have to say my second job of
all time was Curb Your Enthusiasm and it
was a pretty big episode for me at least
that I was playing Larry David's
assistant his secretary and I was
wondering a crop top and really tight
jeans and I was just very confident in
who I was and what my body looked like
and he just thought I should wear maybe
a longer shirt to work and so it's this
whole long episode about that you're
seeing latest script and oh reminder you
have lunch with Richard Lewis both of
you okay thanks what is that I you see
this from my mom all the time
yep but it was so surreal sitting across
from Larry David and Jerry Seinfeld was
also in it and the way they shoot that
show is so unlike anything else you show
up and you have no idea what you're
gonna shoot that day and then you walk
in and they hand you some sides and say
okay here's the five things you're gonna
get on in this scene are you got are you
ready to go and the cameras are already
up and rolling and ready and then you
walk in there like Oh Jerry Seinfeld is
gonna be in this as well you know so
it's it I mean there's a lot being
thrown at you and you just go here we go
I'm either going to fail or do okay
those are the two options does that feel
like you're being thrown in the deep end
or are you kind of confident in your
abilities I honestly when I auditioned
for it I I did this thing where I went
and there was a bunch of other women in
the waiting room that I knew through
Groundlings and UCB and and all of them
look so nervous and I'm like it's just
it's a
improvised audition it'll be fun I
didn't know why everyone was so nervous
and then I found out right before I went
in that Larry David was in the room so I
was just like oh that's why that's very
normal to be terrified about that and so
I made this decision that I was just
gonna call him by his first name very
confidently and see if that made me look
more confident as an improviser and I
got the job so it's very exciting you
know like that yeah I just kept saying
Larry so if you watch the episode it
might be fun to do a drinking game of
how many times I say like I'm always
open to things like that well this
always wonder whenever I walk into a
junket room and it's some like big
celebrity that I've admired their entire
career like like do I call them by their
first name and do what use the full name
or do I suppose yeah you you go hello
Tom Cruise I have wood dude I don't know
what I would say what do you say I don't
think I've ever actually said to Tom
Cruise hello anything I've just been
like thank you so much for your time
thank you if I'm worthy of even a
fraction of a second right now yeah well
there's either I guess I don't yeah I
think there's a few ways to go about it
maybe Tommy is way too confident yeah
cruise cruise whatever you land there's
control the next the next thing I cover
of his I'm gonna bring this up we didn't
please call him cruise control for me
and see how it goes a deal if for
whatever reason I wind up covering the
new Top Gun movie I'm going to say hello
cruise control just to see what happens
what if he just goes Wow and then looks
like I'd watch that probably make for a
great clip that a lot of people would
watch but I don't know how good I know I
hope it goes well for you I feel like my
stairs also another challenging I had no
clue what to say water yeah what do you
say um again I just decided to say
nothing at all and say I loved a star is
born you are phenomenal in it I'm so
happy to be sitting here right now was
she amazing - no she was amazing yeah I
want to interview Lady gaga
I would like to see you interview Lady
Gaga I'm around and available let's make
that happen okay time soon I wanted to
ask you also about 22 drum Street
because as a big movie fan that was the
game changer for me the second I saw you
and that I'm like oh watch
for this one right now some curious from
the earth perspective did all of a
sudden after that movie came out movie
offers start pouring in well I wouldn't
say they poured it but a lot more is
coming my way it was really lovely I
feel like I had just done workaholics
and had some luck with that and then 22
Jump Street came and it started to
change a little bit day to day life
slightly it was it was very interesting
but it was such a great job yeah I mean
I got to just make fun of Jonah Hill all
day long and improvise with him and we
got to do it with the best freak'n fight
scene that they wrote it was it was a
blast thought of me as a person instead
of a woman he hit me and knocked a bad
about it bring it dog girl fight
Oh oh my god is there blood in my head
are you a learn how to hit that one is a
very acceptable performance
actually I'm thinking about something
else that I saw on your IMDB even before
that and you were in Brighton yep what
was it I had a part I can't believe you
told my letters I was bright yeah I was
either bridal guest one or two it was me
and my friend Ariane and we walked by as
like Kristen Wiig is coming in for the
first time so you see me walk by like
this
[Music]
beautiful funny true story my father
loves going to the movies he always went
to the movies every Sunday of his life
and he went to go see Brides maybe he
was so excited told everyone about it he
blinked when I walked by he did not see
me so he went for a second time I was
just like okay she got off the horse now
where is she and yeah so I'm in it movie
got to see twice I have a friend that I
call fun Kelly because they're very fun
and she always writes me and says I want
to congratulate you again on your
continued bridesmaid success so kind of
puts me in my place I feel like I was a
great thank you I know it was wonderful
what was it like for you just standing
there and watching you know these
outstanding performers like Kristen Wiig
to operate is it just basically you know
an opportunity for you to obviously do
what you have to do in that moment but
to sit back and watch someone like her
work I mean I love Kristen I got to read
on SNL with her and we've tried to get
so many sketches on the air at that
nobody it was everyone said no it was
just they were all so crazy some would
make it to dress and then never make it
to air but we had such a good time
writing and her and Maya Rudolph like
all of these women just my comedy icons
so how do you get brought in for a show
like that and what's kind of the process
of getting a sketch to air I was in the
sunday company at The Groundlings which
is a part it's you're not officially a
groundling yet you have you you're still
a part of the school so every Sunday we
were doing like a Saturday Night Live so
every Sunday was a new show where you're
putting up sketches you know on a
Tuesday night you find out what's in
Wednesday or Thursday and you put
together like you produce it basically
so you're you're getting the costumes
and all the props and and making sure
you're memorized and ready to go and
then on Sunday we would do the show and
Lorne Michaels and Seth Meyers and a
couple others came out to the show to
watch it and thank God I didn't know
they were in the audience because I
would have never had a word come out of
my mouth and they asked me to come
audition for the show and then a couple
weeks later I found out I didn't get it
which was crushing so that was my goal
in life was to be on that show and then
I got the call that Seth wanted to meet
me he was the head writer at the time to
be a potential new writer
so that's how it kind of came together
and I went out found out that did the
interview and then that night he called
me and said you got the job and you
start tomorrow and then next week and
fly out to LA pack up your life and move
to New York that's crazy
there's a whirlwind I also wanted to ask
you a little bit about jumping in to
this because we know you've had great
success so far with studio comedies and
this is a comedy Britney runs marathon
is a comedy but there's also so much
more to it that really makes it stand
out so I'm just curious was that kind of
a deliberate choice for you in finding a
project like this I definitely wanted to
switch things up a little bit because
you know if you keep doing the same
thing then people are like oh I know
what to expect of this person and the
beginning of this film at least with the
script read sort of like Oh some stuff
that I've already done before and then
it makes a hard turn sort of in the
doctor's office scene there's a scene
early on where it switches and it sort
of becomes a little bit more real and we
get to look at we have a raw look into a
real woman who these kind of characters
I've played what their backstories or
are and it's a little bit more lair than
some of the stuff I think I've done
before I've loved all of it but you know
this one definitely took a bigger toll
out of me yeah I can understand that but
it was worth it because it takes it
takes a big good toll out of everybody
and hopefully it encourages whether it's
running or something else encourages
people to take you know that one baby
step to get themselves to do that big
thing I was just saying that to someone
I was saying it you know it could be
anything from like breaking up with
someone where it's not a healthy
relationship or I'm making a phone call
to a parent and having a difficult
conversation you know but it's like it's
just encouraging to see the beginning of
the movie how how far she comes
throughout speaking of the very
beginning of the movie I loved the scene
in the theater where you're welcoming
people and the things how much improv
went into something like that
they're a whole bunch of you know extra
footage that we're gonna get on a DVD
special feature night one night I feel
like that was the one scene like with
Paul he was very clear that he just
wanted to try and try to not do as much
improv with this movie and and then once
he got and said I think he was like
let's play around with a couple parts
and that was the scene where we sort of
improvised a lot and played around and a
lot of it stayed in the movie I could
imagine you could probably go on and on
and on in that setting and we would have
watched like ten more minutes oh that's
very nice it also had me thinking what
happens when either you know you're up
there performing stand-up you're in a
movie or just like generally in life
what happens when you try to make
someone laugh and it doesn't work like
what's your go-to mechanism to bounce
back that's happened so many times I
can't tell you I mean even on a talk
show I've been on in Mike why did you do
that moment like it was going so well
and then you were like let it and it
just doesn't work I don't know you just
try to make fun of yourself and move on
and hope that no one noticed that you've
bombed so hard yeah this is why I don't
make very many jokes and I lean on
everybody else when I'm sitting with to
do it for me that's not true you're very
funny a delightful I also love the
character of Demetrius in this movie so
I was wondering who is the Demetrius to
you just that person that no matter
what's going on in your life you know
you could always turn to them and
they've got you back that's definitely
my sister my my sister and I are five
years apart
Brianna Bell she's the best she we lived
together we worked together we're gonna
start producing together soon we have a
t-shirt line together we do ever
we hang out non-stop like she's my best
bud in the whole world and I actually
feel bad for my future husband because
I'm like that's my soul mate right there
yeah she's a sister that I think you
know just as highly really he's
wonderful how many years a pretty good
um we're two and a half years that's
great yeah
so you were in high school together was
that hard well actually so we're two and
a half years apart but I'm a November
baby and she's a February baby so we
were separated by an extra grade but I
to a high school that had 8th through
12th grade so we had I think we have one
maybe two years together oh wow we live
together and she got me into half
marathons really oh yeah that's right I
can't believe your tie I still can't
believe how long that journeys been but
I am here before you jumped into
Brittany runs 'american did you have any
interest in running races at all no no
no not at all I mean I looked up on
Pinterest from couch to 5k just to
figure out how much do you start right
I'm like do you just start running five
miles immediately what are you doing you
know and and or three miles four five
K's but I know I didn't know what I was
doing but I had my sister tape me
running and like figuring it out at the
beginning I was like I don't want any
trainers or anything because I want I
want the beginning of the film to
reflect where I was when I first started
running I just thought that would be you
know I could pull from real life
experience and what it's like when
you're trying to make healthy meals or
healthier decisions for the first time
and how hard it is because a big part of
the film that I didn't really relate to
when I first read it was sort of how
hard it was for her when she first
started and I'm like well just get into
it just started and I'm like I've never
done this journey for myself what was
your version of day one so she stands at
the door she can barely open in right
and I think what happens is she looks at
her reflection and walks right back in
so what was day one of your time running
like oh man I definitely put on the
wrong running shoes I was wearing pants
my sister kept laughing at me because I
was wearing pants that had like a
drawstring but it wasn't quite tight
enough and so they were falling and I
kept holding the back of them and I was
you know I I was holding my arms too
tight to my body just things that are
that's not good yeah just things that at
the beginning you don't know you don't
know to like keep it lighter and and
lead from your heart from your chest and
and all the things that you eventually
learn when you start to do it more and
more but I had no idea well at least you
actually semi did it that first time
when I was in high school I used to play
all the team sports but whenever the
warm-up for that days practice was a
mile run I would just like hang out the
locker room until they were done and
then all of a sudden I would
out and I would join breakfast you'd be
like wow that's so hard for all of us
I'm so hot and sweaty right now that I
feel good all the endorphins Wow yeah
what's the best piece of running advice
someone gave you for this entire process
oh hey I'm just saving all this for
myself now
well um somebody was telling me because
I didn't know where to lead from and
somebody was saying that you kind of do
Care Bear stare which is like it's
pouring out from your chest so we're
always okay from there a little bit into
an 80's 90's trials that makes a yeah
that makes a lot of things I was like
got it
that clips that made sense to me I like
that I have to I have to think about all
that kind of stuff just like posture is
a big deal to I'm sitting here like this
this whole interview my mother is gonna
watch this and be like Jillian well it's
okay I will be suffering the same okay
good we're both in this together
so going back to something you were
saying before did you shoot all of
Britney runs a marathon in order like in
sequence no we shoot we shot out of
sequence so with some of it I had to
have different looks so for some of it I
had prosthetics and a bodysuit and we
had I think three different body suits
throughout the whole journey but yeah it
was only because we were shooting for I
think it was like 26 to 27 days so I
actually did the whole physical journey
of it I lost 40 pounds training and just
run out learning how to do it myself and
then getting a real trainer and then at
the end getting a real like running a
marathon training coach so that I could
he could tell me you know how to hold
your body right and how to hold your
body wrong you know they're depending on
where we were in there in the shooting
so as you said as you hold your body
right I like I was like this buddy right
so how much did you end up hitting
mileage why is have you ever run why I
thought or is that kind of on your
bucket list now it's not on my bucket
list
I definitely look at people who run
marathons like yourself coming up and go
wow that's incredible such a feat you're
a superhero I mean it's just I'm in awe
of people who can do that as am i my
sister has done it and I am in awe of
her and you're gonna do it though
you can't go I feel like I will have a
little more confidence when the mileage
creeps up a little higher most I've ever
done at this point is 13.1 not a lot
though we one else freaked me out in
this movie too and the at one point
someone brings up the idea of having to
use the restroom oh yes I know sometimes
people go to the bathroom while they're
running so did you have you spoken to
many people who have run marathons and
have confirmed that like does that
happen it's interesting because I feel
like it's it's been happening now more
that the movie has been at festivals and
people have been coming up to me and me
and that's the thing that's such a huge
compliment is one people like yourself
who are saying oh I want to do it now
I'm gonna sign up which blows my mind
and makes me so thrilled but also
runners coming up to me and saying like
you nailed it this is exactly what it is
which is a more of a compliment
compliment I think to Paul because he's
the writer/director first my future
director yeah blows my mind huge at that
that's a really big deal I know did he
come to set with something with like a
super specific vision in mind like did
he have a personification he knew there
wasn't a question I had about the script
that he didn't have an answer to I mean
he thought of every every single line
meant something there was not something
in there that didn't go along with what
he wanted the theme of the film to be
and I think he just did such an amazing
job he really did and you're the whole
ensemble here has so much chemistry
goodness this is another thing that you
don't expect that you get from this
movie and I think this is an idea that a
lot of people have a hard time with is
being able to take help from other
people without like your initial
reaction being like oh like you mean
that as an insult
yeah not being open to the people who
are there supporting you it's a huge
part of the film yeah there's also we
also deal with like toxic friendships
and like letting go of people who aren't
filling you and I think that's a huge
message especially to get across to I
would have liked to have seen a movie
about that in my 20s at least you know
just just not spending extra energy on
people that aren't building you up yeah
I keep thinking there's so many movies
coming out now that I
wish I had seen when I was young right
yes probably would have been on the
running path a little sooner had I seen
this I mean the combination of my sister
in this movie is exactly what I and
actually another thing that really kind
of hit home for me with this is the idea
of not getting in through the lottery
and having to raise money because that's
right that's like another intimidation
factor there that you build up the
courage to actually push submit on a
form and then you might not get in and
then you have to you know it's for a
good cause but it's very intimidating to
have to Rania's a couple thousand
dollars so intimidating especially if
you're not financially in the right
place right in that moment and you still
want to do this huge thing and exactly
it's you know but then you find
something super important to you like
pets and running for North Shore Animal
League right and it's just it's another
motivating sad is that yeah
oh I love that a big pet person I'm a
bin app thing I have to ask do you have
any pets
I have to I have to know beautiful
delicious dogs I have a German Shepherd
mix his name's Vallejo he's about eight
and then I have a puppy I I mean she's a
handful and I love her so much her
name's gypsy and she is a great date
night
oh wow okay big momma you've got big
dogs yeah a big dog and you're in New
York City with the dogs well no they
couldn't travel with me my sister was
watching them for me because they would
attack the city there would be a ten
attack on the city yeah it would just be
two dogs and they would take it over
can you go running with them I have to
do it separately but yeah they're pretty
good although the Great Dane is sort of
like I'm done like immediately and
Vallejos a really good runner oh yeah I
can't run with my cat but it's fine with
your cat I know I could like put him in
a backpack and run with I fear that this
would become the background he would
make me so miserable have you ever seen
the cat backpacks with like a little
bubble in it though no I feel like
that's a thing that I could at least
just experiment with I guess wait
there's a bubble it's like a backpack
and then there's like a bubble that juts
out so the cat has a little window to
kind of look out that is amazing please
get this I we
control that's wise we say welcome back
you're making your life so much better
and a marathon look at your new life
yeah it's a big year I also asked you a
lot about the individual that this movie
is based on because I couldn't really
find too much about her online so can
you tell me a little bit about the
original yeah Brittany O'Neil she's
wonderful human beings she's so
inspiring I mean to have this story be
inspire you know her her life story
inspired this story and and you know I
think I'm always want to check in on her
I'm like how are you doing because this
is a big deal and and also to see you
know your friend think of you and how
how did how do they portray you in the
movie and she's really really happy with
it which makes me in turn very happy did
you get to work with her at all while
you were actually doing the movie I am
more sticking to the script I met her
while we were filming so she came on a
day that was super emotional and I just
kept saying to Paul because Paul this is
his best friend
so they've known each other since
college and that's why you know they
were roommates together and inspired the
whole thing and and I just kept saying
check in on her I just want to make sure
she's okay because that's a lot to walk
into you know maybe a moment that
happened in your real life and there's
some silly actress portraying it and and
hopefully being careful with it but you
know that's a lot - can you imagine some
moment in your life where you're like
this wasn't my proudest moment and now
someone's shooting is going through my
mind right I probably wouldn't be all
that pleased with it who would you want
to play you in a movie so I've actually
thought about this a lot because our
wonderful viewers out there just think
that any actress with bangs should play
me great so like I get Felicity Jones
every once in a while though one that
I've ever done a double take and it's
only because of one specific picture on
her Instagram that someone showed okay
is constant constant Zimmer oh yes there
I can see that there was just one
picture that someone sent me on her
Instagram like they said that's nice
that picture I thought it was you and
that was the first time that I looked at
a picture of her and I'm like oh I love
that that's a great white vinyl you see
one day I have to interview her and make
sure we both have bangs yeah yeah I want
to go back to what you brought up about
your sister about you guys producing
together because one thing in the
industry that I see a lot right now that
really excites me our actors taking hold
of their career and kind of using that
weight that they build through their
performances to actually make the movies
that they want to make the better about
and have that kind of control so what's
what's the gold you guys have a company
name or specific project you have your
eye on we do have a company name is
called Sora pictures and it's Sora's
Romanian for sisters and we are going to
produce a movie that I wrote so that's
happening it's very exciting so I'm
working on the rewrite for that right
now and then hopefully we'll get other
people attached and you know the whole
spiel but you were an EP on this right
yes so what did you learn from executive
producing Britney that you're gonna take
onto that project you know I have
produced before on a show called idiot
sitter that I created and and I really
enjoy producing I love being a part of
problem solving especially on the day if
there's you know we only have this much
time and we have to cut a scene or
something like that like I love being a
part of like figuring out how we can
make everything work and I also love
getting very involved in the script
early on and with Paul it was just daily
conversations about each scene and what
they meant and the motivation behind it
and why a certain character would say
something or write they wouldn't and and
also being in the editing Bay I really
enjoy that yeah so I like producing I'm
I'm hoping to someday try directing and
and see if that's a fit who knows I
could be terrified be like if I have
that itch you have to at least try to
scratch it once otherwise it's always
gonna be in the back you know I gotta
try it I mean I wrote a short film so I
might I might try to direct that was a
good place to start and all be in it so
that I don't ruin anyone else's career
if it's a you want to direct and I'll
direct myself I'm like you're doing
horrible and I'm a bad director
like the idea of that being a short like
you know yeah good short I'm pretty sure
I would watch that should we write it
what are you doing tonight I love her I
actually thought about that because I'm
like I'm going to the gym to do my visit
with their marathon stir I'm I'm not the
biggest fan of yoga I have to get into
it but the joke I do go to offers a
gymnastics class which teaches you like
certain like flexibility to go a little
more exciting to me you're doing so much
right now yeah not as much as you you
were just telling me before that you
were all over the place
I'm traveling a lot but that allows like
a lot of sitting around on a plane but
this that's huge I mean yoga and
gymnastics and running it's a lot well
know you're taking that off but we okay
yeah okay hang on junior maybe maybe
after I don't love the classes I feel
like someone always yells at me a
teacher you do especially by whenever I
do go to a class with my sister the two
of us are usually like I'm talking the
entire time oh yeah I'm like it's not
working I don't feel it and I think my
body's doing something wrong and they're
like it's because you are doing
something wrong you're not listening and
paying attention yeah I have that
problem
CrossFit actually this is the most la
thing I could say and everyone has told
me that cuz the first thing I did when I
moved out to LA was join a CrossFit gym
because the community there like it yes
it's intimidating the lifts all that way
and everything but the community there
is so supportive and it's great there's
nothing better than having people around
you like even if it's just a matter of
someone saying like you can do it a
little bit longer yeah
makes it that really helps that really
helps I feel like this is the worst
transition but you were bringing up
earlier traveling all the time I'm
curious now what is your go-to thing to
make the flights go by faster I do watch
anything or like oh I watch movies I
nothing makes me happier than when I get
in and see that there's a TV screen I'm
like oh gosh what am I gonna get in and
and then I always have the struggle of
am I gonna watch something older that I
love or am I not watch something new
that had a big problem honey yeah what
do you watch well I shouldn't say this
but I've used the screen link I got
this way too much you watch this oh
great too many times though okay so have
me earlier I did the same thing with
Wild Rose where I just I find favorites
and write all my favorite movies of 2019
I've seen in the theater too like
multiple times oh that's great I always
go to a movie if you I saw it four times
in the theaters I saw that is one of the
best dancers you could have said just
get out six times
I mean I just love and I love going and
watching it with someone who hasn't seen
it yet and they're gasping or what do
you do cuz I run into this all the time
cuz it's like I like to bring my friends
to my favorite movies bring my parents
to my favorite movies and obviously they
have different tastes so ya get super
nervous when I'm going into a favorite
with someone and they walk out and they
are not as high on it as I am pleased to
bummer yeah what do you do when you're
in that situation I just I try to be a
grown-up I have a really hard time being
a grown-up in those situations cuz I'm
like but it's do i but the this is why
it's the greatest thing you've ever seen
they're like Jillian blade face eight is
not the greatest thing we've ever seen
I'm like put the blade in his face
what's a recent movie that you
absolutely fell in love with that you
think either didn't get enough love at
the box office or critic like oh my god
that's a great question
let me think oh you know what well it
might have gotten some good reviews but
I loved Mandy
so what you gonna do
it's crazy evil Mandy is so good
we don't call Collider nightmares here
and I think we bring up Mandy like every
other I loved Mandy it's great I I'm sad
that I didn't see it in the theater so
that's the way to see it sadly I didn't
either and I feel like that was a missed
opportunity there should be if I thought
that they should bring it back into the
theaters of people who were late to the
game yeah yeah I love Nicholas Cage
I mean he's something else in that that
lovely maniac I can't wait to see him in
anything he's in he always attacks it
hard it makes me so happy if you like
that style of Nicolas Cage you should
watch mom and dad on Netflix too oh yes
I want to see that goes for in him and
selma Blair or the perfect pair
I will watch that get seen vampire's
kiss no I have it I couldn't think of a
more horrible job if I wanted to and you
have to do it you have to well why are
you do you understand and that's why
tonight welcome writing a short film
putting that on the list but another
thing I like to do to get more movies on
my list is ask somebody what is the
movie that you quote the most and
whether I've seen it or not I'm just
gonna watch it oh what's the movie I
quote the most oh you know what it's a
bummer answer because I've already said
this but a clue it's got to be clue if
it's your favorite movie of all time
it's a very appropriate answer I would
say clue or mannequin too on the move I
love very much I actually for my
birthday I do this thing where I this
company comes out and blows up a huge
screen in my back yard and I have my
friends come over like the Hollywood
Cemetery the screenings in Los Angeles
and everyone brings like a fold-out
chair and we watch a movie that I love
and we did valley girl last year and we
did mannequin two on the moon this year
it's so much fun because a lot of people
you know if they haven't seen it or if
they have seen and and loved it like
it's just a fun little outing movies are
always my go-to for my birthday and this
year because it felt I think it falls
out on my birthday maybe it's frozen -
oh that's very exciting to be the one to
say it's gonna be wonderful sisters not
five so I've got to do it oh yeah so
usually I like to wrap up with a bunch
of
lighter random questions and they're
random questions that like I don't
really have them written down either I'm
just gonna pull the ones out of my brain
that I think of first Oh what is the
most spontaneous thing you've done
recently oh okay sure I I went to France
for this trip I came out out of the blue
and I was sort of like oh I love being
in my home I like laying in my bed and
watching Dateline but I was like I can't
miss out on this opportunity so I went
to France a good one to have gone with
the travel that we do in this industry
never been to France
Jessica got to put that on the bucket
list what is the background photo on
your phone it's a picture I found on
Pinterest that's it's like a little
cartoon drawing of all things fall which
it's not fall right now but I it's from
last year but it's like a witch's hat
and like a cup of hot chocolate and the
leaves falling Halloween isn't my
favorite I call it my favorite time of
year Halloween is its own time of year
this will make you feel better
I bought Halloween decorations my first
year in LA so three years ago now so
great 2016 Halloween and I bought like
this crappy little thing in CVS and it
was a it was a pumpkin with a skeletons
body and I hung it on my door it is
still on my door and has not come down
since Halloween 2016 this makes me feel
like we're gonna be friends yeah yeah
I'm very excited about that that makes
me so happy
yeah that thing makes me happy every
single time I come home you go to the
haunted hayride oh I do everything great
hungry you're in hay reversal yeah
Halloween Horror Nights is a must have
you ever done any of the immersive scary
story kind of experience I did one and
this woman I think she was a great
actress if you're out there I don't
remember what it was called though so
that's not gonna help us but you I was
in one and she was like I got separated
from my group can I hang out with you
guys were like yeah of course this is
terrifying and then all of a sudden a
wall just like a part of a wall open and
she was taken like pulled out of the
room and we're like oh you're part of it
you got us so good like she what I
thought she was a Jen it genuinely
from her group I'd love that that would
have delighted me sir right much so wait
are you a thrill seeker would you do
skydiving and all that kind of some love
it I even loved all of that stuff I've
never been skydiving hide it twice
highly recommended oh you should
probably go in a more exotic location
than where I did but you should go okay
okay diving over you know the eastern
end of Long Island is not as visually
pleasing as many people's experiences
it's still about the experience yeah
flying out of a plane jumping out it is
it's an important thing to get done if
you want to do it actually
rollercoasters could you're talking
about them before like what's your
favorite roller coaster that you've been
on favorite roller coaster oh I told you
the the Tower of Terror at Disney World
was my favorite not even just ride but
my favorite place in the world I had
someone asked me once if you could be
anywhere right now where would you be
you know Greece or Italy I'm like a
tower of terror I immediately said it
that's my favorite place that's such a
good one
I do like the new guardians of the
galaxy ride that they oh right out here
at Disneyland but terror of terror will
always have a special place because it's
the mix of horror and you know the
thrill right you need more stuff like
yeah serious question who is someone in
the industry right now that is changing
things for the better that really
inspires you director actor anyone you
want oh my gosh there's so many people I
I mean I think Jamila Jamila Jamila I
think whoever in Cox I think she's more
of a musician but Liz oh I I mean I'm
inspired by so many people right now I
can't my head is exploding also because
I was just like I told you in France
yeah and I'm jet-lagged but there's so
many people doing Ilana Glazer there's
there's so many great people that are
out there fighting the good fight and
and I'm so happy that they are and to be
a smaller part of that as am i because
it means more people to come initially
you oh thank you who is the unsung hero
on Britney runs a marathon we know you
we always know the director the writer
like who is someone doing a job over
there that many people out there might
not be aware of that you want to
right now I think a lot of people are
aware of Michaela Watkins but she is I
should not be able to just have a
conversation with her she is a superstar
when whenever I had a scene with her I
would find myself not remembering to say
my line because I was just watching her
with my jaw on the floor she's
incredible and everyone in the cast is
amazing
I also want to give a shout out to harsh
because he is he the next he's so heated
man he's so romance lead like he's he's
unstoppable
I quite put a finger on it like why but
there is something so special about him
we're the first time I ever saw him and
it's perfect one like you that guy you
or something that guys go on place
[Music]
I feel like I already have my answers to
this but I was looking at your IMDB page
and one thing that I've come to love to
do on IMDB before an interview is scroll
through the random trivia because
there's usually like like random garbage
there for like a super like short
snippet of an interview that makes no
sense whatsoever but Marvin there wasn't
a lot there for you okay so I want you
to tell me what is something you could
tell me about yourself whether it's
something you did or something you like
that would like blow people's minds they
would never expect okay let me think one
I'm dying to play a witch that's all I
want to do in my career is play a witch
what who is pocus I mean I would lose my
I feel like we're getting like one of
the the TV movies for that like they're
doing a new TV movie or something but I
feel like if they ever bring focus
brothers it is a big screen there's a
sequel yeah but I think all the original
yeah but any anything which related I
would be excited to do right
I'm rakhna phobic I'm terrified of
spiders when I'm in this big when you
find a spider cry a little bit I I will
get very scared have you ever seen in
those you know like the the magazines
with all like the random products it's
got the the vacuum with like a super
long hose on it so you could suck up the
spider from far away oh that's the idea
I only have learns about that after I
moved into my own apartment by myself
for the first time and a big spider was
there and I didn't know what to do so my
teeny tiny Dustbuster I sucked it up
into that but then I realized it's still
alive in my dust box oh no no oh no yeah
that's terrible
yeah even knew just doing this while you
were telling the story scares me I can't
even watch the video there was that
great video that went viral of the dog
who was dressed with the spider legs
who's running after the human I can't
watch it you're so hands they're one of
the funniest viral videos I've seen oh
my goodness I think it's a dachshund too
or something yeah anything really guys
and my friend Cisco just you can watch
this one and I can't do it you can't do
it what other things can I tell you I I
told you in this Isle of Dateline it's
my favorite show of all time
I love Keith Morrison and Josh
mankiewicz they're my good friends in my
head i weirdly do know josh mankiewicz
now we went out for drinks so that you
could tell me more about murder and it
was the greatest night of my life yeah
you could say that to me and I will not
judge whatsoever given all the stuff
that I take in all the time I feel like
I failed to bring up final destination
in this conversation and it's really
disappointing me right now well because
we were really going into great detail
about it before the cameras were rolling
and your favorite is the second one
second one what is your favorite horror
film of all time scream scream what's
your favorite horror film of all time I
think it's honestly Texas Chainsaw
Massacre with Jessica Biel oh you know
so Texas Chainsaw Massacre the area I
use the full title it's with Jessica
Biel no it's not is that the beginnings
no the beginnings or that's the remake
that's is the remake oh and then they
started they made like two more after
that I liked both that one and the
beginning yes a bit great so those need
those need a better reputation yeah I
have yeah I feel like we ended on a high
note here well we did somehow yeah all
right
that is a wrap on this edition of
colliders lady collateral ladies night
Julian thank you so much for playing
today's was so much fun thank you for
making a movie that was a major source
of inspiration for me because I'm gonna
run America I can't wait I wish I could
be in New York with a big sign my
sister's gonna be there with her newborn
baby my whole family it's gonna be a
wonderful November I think this year is
the cat gonna be the bubble backpack
that I should I don't know if that'll be
okay he's so mad if I put him back on a
plane to go cross-country don't you baby
I'll encourage my my parents to bring
the dogs and not trust them up spiders
oh yeah please for everyone's sake and
just because I have two billion gel
thank you so much for being here on
Collider ladies like guys thank you so
much please keep an eye out for Britney
runs a marathon you do not want to miss
this I promise you that we will see you
soon with more ladies night
[Applause]
[Music]